for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out
movie University com thank you and enjoy
so in this video we're going to name
covalent compound specifically binary
covalent compounds a binary covalent
compounds basically we have just one non
metal and another non metal right there
are just two binary refers to two okay
so we're going to name each of these
elements sort of separately the first
one that we see the first one listed in
the formula we're going to put a prefix
right indicating how many of them there
are right unless unless there's just one
okay as far as the first element goes
okay and that prefix will be followed by
the elements name okay that'll be for
the first element for the second element
we're going to have the prefix
regardless of its just one we're going
to have a prefix no matter what and
following that will have the elements
name with the root ending in I'd right
okay so best explained with examples so
we have CF 4 as the first one okay so
that's going to be the first elements
going to be carbon right in the second
one is going to be fluorine so this
first part here applies to the first
element so we're going to prefix wait no
we won't because it says unless there's
just one of them and I notice here that
there's just one carbon so I don't need
a prefix I'm just going to put the
element named so i'll put carbon I will
not put mono carbon just carbon okay and
then I'm going to follow that with a
prefix indicating the number of the next
element right so in this case I have
four fluorines right so for the prefix
is tetra so carbon tetra and then I have
the element named ending and I'd so
fluorine would be fluoride so this would
be carbon tetra full right now it would
be for that okay next up I've got
nitrogen and oxygen now do I need a
prefix here well I've got two nitrogens
right to of that first element so I do
to prefix there so I'm going to put the
prefix for two in front of nitrogen so
the prefix for two is die so die
nitrogen dinitrogen and I have four
oxygens so the prefix for four is tetra
so tetra and then oxygen would become
oxide so dinitrogen tetroxide now
sometimes when there's two vowels there
they just change that too they'll just
write it as oops dinitrogen dinitrogen
tetroxide so let's just drop da there
okay I'll just drop that little that a
there but I've seen both so I'm going to
go with both in this video okay next up
we got p 40 10 so i'm going to need a
prefix for the first element there's for
the prefix for four is tetra so tetra p
is phosphorus so tetra phosphorus tetra
phosphorus and we've got oxygen there's
ten of them the prefix for ten is deca
so we'll have Tetris watch first deca
and then o is oxygen oxide so deca oxide
or just tetra phosphorus tetra
phosphorus deck oxide lovely I made
plenty of room there so yeah tetra
phosphorus dick deca oxide or attach a
phosphorus deck oxide okay like I said
I've seen both I think more commonly
they drop the a but I've seen both which
is why I'm putting both in the video
before anyone comments with with a sort
of tons of exclamation points telling me
about how wrong I am ok next one is f2
ok how are you named this ok joke's on
you this isn't actually a binary
covalent compound I just do this one in
here this would just be for een right
this is elemental fluorine because it's
one of the seven diatomic elements right
the others are h2
you n 2 o 2 CL 2 br2 and I to write I
just put this here to remind you to go
study 7 diatomic elements if you don't
already know them okay next up we've got
s 2 br2 okay so s 2 i'm going to need to
prefix for that s so that's going to be
die sulfur alright because there are two
sulfur's and the prefix for two again
die bro me becomes bromide so dibromide
die so for dibromide so next up I have
h2o so I'm going to have died hydrogen
and there's only one oxygen so now I do
need the prefix right because the second
one always needs a prefix so there's one
of them so that's mono so it's going to
be monoxide all right in that case we're
definitely dropping we're not going to
have mono oxide I've never seen that
before okay but you guys have probably
already know h2o commonly as water right
water nh3 that would be nitrogen we can
don't have I have to have a prefix for
for that one because it's already just
one right so nitrogen and there's three
hydrogen's so that would be try right
according to the prefix try try hydride
right nitrogen ty hydride okay that one
is commonly known as ammonia and I'm
going to put these actually in
parenthesis these common names here okay
nh3 is commonly known as ammonia okay
ch4 so 1 C so that will just be carbon
no prefix right carbon and then for four
hydrogen's would be tetra hydride but
that one also has a common name methane
and it's actually a hydrocarbon which
we're going to learn a little bit more
about how to name hydrocarbons in the
next video specifically the alkanes but
I do mention here that you should
memorize the common names of those three
because they come up so often that it
would just be ashamed not to know them
okay so definitely keep those in mind
and practice practice this with a bunch
of different exam
I'm sure you can find some either on
your homeworks or problem sets or even
online if you just look up practice for
naming anyway I hope that video is
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying